incredible claims have surfaced from
former national security advisor john
bolton and it is now believed that john
bolton regularly questioned whether
donald trump was acting in the best
interests of the united states it's an
almost unbelievable revelation but i
want to be careful using that language
i've said before when we say you won't
believe the next thing donald trump
theater the last thing Donald Trump did
it does in a sense maybe implicitly
foment a lack of belief that this is the
real world so I want to be careful about
using those terms the new battle lines
in impeachment as we've talked about are
Ken Donald Trump's former national
security adviser John Bolton
be trusted John Bolton says it in his
upcoming book that Donald Trump
personally told him withhold the
military aid to Ukraine until Ukraine
announces the smear investigations into
Joe Biden Democrats want john bolton to
testify in donald trump's impeachment
trial republicans seemingly do not they
are smearing john bolton as a tool of
the radical left on fox business that
was lou dobbs we played those clips
earlier for you eventually probably
friday the senate will vote as to
whether they are going to call witnesses
and whether john bolton is going to be
one of those witnesses now republicans
don't want him to testify despite saying
hey we would love some first-hand
accounts as part of this impeachment
trial and despite john bolton being able
to provide exactly that republicans
don't want him to testify so now it is
all about can we really trust john
bolton
to tell the truth and every single day
this is what they say by the way every
single day we hear from more from john
bolton which tells me we have to hear
from him in the senate trial it it is an
absolute imperative that we hear from
john bolton more revelations now from
john Bolton's upcoming book reveal that
when bolton was donald trump's national
security adviser that relative
relatively brief period bolton was
regularly appalled that's a quote
regularly appalled by the behavior of
donald trump and that John Bolton
sometimes couldn't tell whether Trump
was acting based on doing what's best
for the United
States or on other nefarious goals
nefarious is Bolton's word not mine
let me say it again in other words
because we are all desensitized to the
insanity of the political status quo in
2020 the National Security Adviser of
the United States when he was in that
position would watch the president's
actions would observe the decisions of
the President and doubted or could not
tell is the president acting with the
interests of the United States in mind
or does the president have other
nefarious interests in mind when he
makes these decisions this is not normal
even if Bolton was wrong in his
assessment the fact that Bolton couldn't
tell in whose interests Donald Trump was
acting is in and of itself a scandal now
let me be very clear John Bolton is one
of the worst reactionary right-wing
pro-war neo cons of the last 20 years
but I don't believe John Bolton would
show up and just lie under oath to the
Senate the way it's being portrayed now
by some on the right is that you can't
believe this guy who Lou Dobbs saying
he's a tool of the radical left he's
linked to bin Minh and Romney and all of
these conspiracy theories that Lou Dobbs
literally charted out with spider map
connections as I showed you earlier
I don't believe Bolton would show up and
lie Donald Trump is already asserting
that John Bolton is simply lying
Donald Trump tweeted in direct
contradiction to John Bolton's claim
quote I never told John Bolton that the
aid to Ukraine was tied to
investigations into Democrats including
the Biden's in fact he never complained
about this at the time of his very
public termination that proves nothing
of course if John Bolton said this it
was only to sell a book now of course
John Bolton may not have said this at
the time of his termination because it
was not immediately relevant now that
that is the subject of impeachment it is
not a far-fetched to believe that John
Bolton is hearing lies being told
recognizes he has knowledge about this
and says well no now I actually have
something to add now I want to show up
and I want to testify we are not dealing
with good people when we talk about
Donald Trump and John Bolton but Trump
lies endlessly about everything all the
time including insignificant things so
if you ask me who do I believe here I
believe John Bolton and I challenge
anyone to make a strong case for why
Donald Trump is more believable here
than John Bolton John Bolton okay he
might want to sell a book right that's
the motivation Donald Trump has been
impeached and the entire case arguing
against the reason for his impeachment
is arguably completely dissolved by the
testimony of John Bolton Bolton might
want to sell some books okay is that
gonna make John Bolton just show up and
lie under oath to the Senate I don't
believe so Donald Trump has his
presidency at stake and is the longtime
historically proven liar doesn't mean
Bolton is anything other than an
architect of the Iraq war but John
Bolton was a guy who was the darling of
the neocon Pro Iraq war right-wing for
more than a decade and because he says I
know what you know I have a story to
tell what's being said publicly isn't
true I will show up and I will tell the
story he is now being trashed by the
administration by Republican officials
by right-wing media like Lou Dobbs on
Fox Business all to try to either
prevent him from testifying altogether
if he testifies make him not believed or
appear to be not credible it's
embarrassing and we we are going to
continue talking about this and we will
know sooner than later whether we are
actually going to hear testimony from
John Bolton I hope that the answer is
yes let me know what you believe do you
believe that we will ultimately hear
testimony from John Bolton in Donald
Trump's Senate impeachment trial privacy
calm is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you $5.00 just for using their
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdraw
from your checking account but your real
card number stays completely private and
you do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman